the Honda insider report brings us
Candace Parker to the Rich Eisen show
how are you Candace hi how are you doing
I'm great
I've really enjoyed what you've been up
to you enjoying it yourself I am
enjoying I'm learning I am you know
obviously it's funny when people say
it's work because I mean I don't think
basketball talking basketball is work so
then it's been a fun experience well but
the work would have to be I guess you
know learning who all these players are
I mean deep down in Nevada and UMBC and
stuff like that I mean I wouldn't know
who these people are off the top of my
head I mean you've had to have done
something on that front right Candace
you know when I was Susan at this
opportunity I think it was like a couple
weeks ago you know three four weeks ago
you know I jumped at the opportunity but
I was a little hesitant because I
watched College men's basketball but I
don't watch you know obviously all 68
teams that were in the tournament um so
I think I was you know kind of like
studying for exams you know I was kind
of crammed in a little bit and trying to
get to know you know all the teams but
really it just has gotten easier as the
tournament's gone on because you know
you see you you're able to see the teams
and and see them play and obviously
there's less team so but this has been
an amazing experience for me just
learning from everybody and sometimes I
have to pinch myself to realize who I'm
sitting at the desk with I know it's and
it's been fun watching you I have fun
with everybody that you have been on on
the desk with Candice Parker here on the
Rich Eisen show so who's set to make the
run what do you think nine minutes you
know I I am a nova believer I watched
them play you know obviously throughout
the years as well as you know through
these first two games in the NCAA
tournament and I wouldn't take my my
prediction with a grain of salt though
because I picked Arizona to to go you
know to the Final Four so I don't know
if I would take what I say and hold it
in high regard but I I like Villeneuve I
like the way they're playing I like
their their deaths and you know I think
they're where they're gonna they're
gonna make the room
okay so then who do you think stands in
their way
who do you think's got the chance to
make sure that that might not actually
materialize is it West Virginia could it
be
Texas Tech or Purdue or maybe in the
lower bracket
Duke Syracuse Clemson what do you think
you know Duke is peaking at the right
time
you know when they're able to mix their
inside outside game devolve hitting
shots now you got great great Gracie
Allen that's knocking down the three and
of course bag me and you know Wendell
Carter juniors are handling inside has
they happen all year so I like Duke I
think you know people aren't really
talking about Texas Tech and I think in
infidelity the key to winning is
obviously you have to have experience at
the guard and you have to have a great
playmaker
you know company that can create in
those brakes broken plays and Texas Tech
has that obviously Evans have been a
huge fan they have tremendous
athleticism with Dyer Smith and you know
it's been fun if anything it's been fun
watching them play and coach K past your
coach Pat Summitt for winningest coach
in basketball college basketball history
Kandace and I'm wondering what you
thought of of his statement I I you know
I kind of I appreciate it that he
basically said that Pat would have won
more if she didn't get sick and that was
his first two cents I'm wondering what
you thought when you heard that that
statistic being mentioned
well first off it's a huge honor for him
to pass coach Summitt I think she really
respected Coach K everything that she
spoke of him you know was with
tremendous respect and high regard and
you know he obviously is one of the best
basketball coaches there ever will be
and I can't think of a better person to
pass her in terms of if you look at
identical philosophies growing the
person not just the athlete you know
being able to change with the games
I think that's underestimated with you
know Coach Summitt changed with the game
of basketball you know she was old
school and she was able to kind of come
into the new school of Basilan I think
that's what made her successful and it's
the same with Coach K so I think you
know along the wins of course that's a
measure of greatness but I think just
their amount of respect that she had
there's not a better person that could
have could have passed her so how
she hard on you how'd she coach you
really hard it was tough love but it was
definitely love and I knew it was coming
from a great place and you know on the
court extremely hard pushed me wanted me
to be the best that set goals set
challenges didn't let me coast but off
the court you know what I remember is
you know her jalapeno corn her homemade
ice cream I remember all that stuff
because she cooked for us all the time
so I just think the reason why another
reason is just in terms of the way that
she was a mother you know to her son and
I think that that's kind of had a huge
influence on the way that I parent my
child so then how do you parent your
child I mean when when it comes out how
did she coach you on that front I'm
fascinated
you know coach Summitt didn't coach with
results and I think that's what I didn't
understand when I was 18 to 22 years old
you know we'd win the game by 30 and
she'd be sitting here talking about
rebounding like but coach we won by 30
like what does that matter and she's
like but we didn't rebound you know and
I was just like you know it may not
matter at that time and I think that's
the way I coach my daughter you know
like before she'd bring home an A and
I'd be like yeah he got an A Congrats
but she didn't study you know she didn't
study for that now I'm I celebrate her
preparation for it you know regardless
of whether she gets a bad grade or a
great grade who celebrates the
preparation and how much time you put
into preparing and how much time it's
been to your craft
so was coach Summitt a better coach or
or cook or chef which one oh my goodness
don't make me choose you most he was a
pretty good cook man I don't know I
think as great of a coach as he was I
think she might have been a better cook
Wow damn take that Coach K let's see
your recipe now Candace Parker of Turner
Sports and of course WNBA and greatness
at Tennessee and in that regard Candace
I'd love for you to try and put yourself
in Virginia's shoes I mean you've been a
top seed in the NCAA tournament knowing
that the 16th seed would love to pull
off the upset of the century and just
watching what UMBC did to Virginia I'd
love to get your perspective on that and
just sitting
watching that game you know Seth Davis
huge fan I mean obviously he works
college basketball but he's just a huge
overall fan of men's backs loss you know
men's college basketball and to see his
excitement you know that it this was
finally happened and um you know
obviously you don't want it to be you
for Virginia because I feel like that's
kind of one of those things that it's
forever going to be attached to your
name you know and I think we forget
sometimes you know how how crazy
basketball is I mean you look at the NBA
and you look at last year even as great
as Golden State was last year San
Antonio had them on the ropes
if Kauai doesn't get hurt San Antonio
has them on the ropes they probably won
Game one at Golden State now that's the
one game thing if that's do-or-die like
one game Golden State's out and they're
probably one of the best teams in the
history of basketball so if you look at
it that way I mean everybody has an off
night it just is unfortunate I mean I
guess it's great for the fans but it's
unfortunate for the players because if
you have one off night you know your
margin for error is uh really small and
when you just mentioned the Warriors
makes me one it wonder if you think this
could be the Rockets here this is
because the Warriors are all banged up
right now I know it's kind of early
right now because we're we're not even
in April yet but what are your two cents
on that Candice Parker
you know the Warriors are so deep and
they haven't even scratched the surface
I mean you do looking at the Warriors
and you got to measure hunger you know
it sucks to have the talent to be able
to turn it on when you want but the
Warriors have the talent to be able to
turn it on when they want you know and
Houston is hungry right now
you know nobody has won a championship
everybody doubted them doubted the
system doubted Chris Paul going there so
they have a lot their back against the
wall playing the where ISM one two out
of the last three championships
you know and they reached the finals no
three straight so I mean I think they're
gonna turn it on and I think it's gonna
be a great series but I think they're
gonna they're gonna make it back to the
final okay a couple more minutes with
Candice Parker here on the Rich Eisen
show in the Honda inside a report are
you and sister Jean all cool with
our problem oh my goodness that one hurt
they asked me whether I would like to
play or watch the game and I think
honestly playing the game is less
nerving than watching have no control
sitting there in a studio but it's but I
I don't know what your take is on this
because you know obviously I've had a
camera trained on me on a studio set
well a team that I have nothing but
passion for is losing and and I I don't
feel it should be a camera on me I take
a little offense to that I mean yeah I
was we had to go on set after that and
so I had to be out there to watch it
because I was watching it in the back
for the whole game and then we walked
out there they got me they got me
especially since you know we celebrated
too soon you celebrate it too soon you
celebrate and one I just assumed that
Tennessee's defense would be able to
lock them up but uh lucky bounce I just
I keep replaying it I know they have to
be sick because I am but they're a good
team everybody's probably coming back
next year so I think okay there's a good
to build on we're learning and how do
you handle the the tournament do you
want now Loyola Chicago the whole way
because they beat your team because that
usually is the way it works for for mere
mortals what about you
I don't know I'm from the Chicago area
yeah I like I think basketball around
Chicago everybody supports and you know
it's kind of a big deal obviously but
you know the the competitive spirit in
me doesn't Building want that to happen
because that could have been Tennessee
no hey look Candace enjoyed the chat
we're here in El Segundo please come by
and studio I'd love to have you here in
person yeah we don't have a curse button
the like area 21 we don't have but we
could have used it yesterday actually it
does thanks for joining appreciate it
look forward to the next time you got at
Candace underscore Parker the Rich Eisen
show weekdays
noon eastern on audience